quand tout d'un coup je vais voir Avatar
en IMAX
et que j'entends des gens qui font oui
mais quand même un bâtard
quoi mais tu as vu l'expérience qu'on te
propose
mais c'est complètement dingue
c'est-à-dire que le mec invente des
nouveaux outils pour pouvoir créer cet
univers qui n'existe pas il y a rien qui
existe de ce que tu vois à l'image tu as
des textures tu as des trucs etc donc là
on parle d'un niveau de cinéma populaire
qui va être très très difficile à
atteindre pour les Français
[Musique]
la mère de tes enfants c'est comme ta
mère tes enfants l'aiment plus que tout
donc tu dois il ne faut pas les
massacrer les tabassé
[Musique]
et comme prends soin tes enfants sont
heureux tu payes la pension
[Musique]